l internet s incompatible everyone L
totally durable totally dairyman
necesita room control the information
can control information control I mean
this is Yuta he's playing World of
Warcraft with a few hundred others in
Havana but he's not connected to the
Internet instead Yuta is using what's
called street net one of the many
bootlegged inventions Cubans have come
up with to bypass their government's
resistance to Internet access five
percent of the 11 million people in Cuba
actually have access to the Internet a
few years ago some young tech savvy
gamers in Havana started connecting
their computers through long Ethernet
cables running them from rooftop to
rooftop across the city and soon they
started using wireless routers to expand
even further
they created a giant mesh network which
has no central server instead each
participant holds a piece of the network
on their local computer
creating nodes that connect the city to
one giant network today there are over
10,000 users connected to Street net
throughout the Havana using the street
net is strangely similar to searching
the real web there are blogs and forums
dating sites and social media that looks
like Facebook you have to remind
yourself that you're actually looking at
an illegal makeshift network invented by
cuban gamers in 1959 Fidel Castro led a
socialist revolution that flipped Cuban
society upside down Castro established a
regime that limited all unapproved
expression punishing anyone who spoke
out against the government decades later
the world started adopting the Internet
hey why should I be on the internet but
Cuba is the most censored country in
Western Hemisphere and the advent of the
Internet in all of its uncontrollable
and decentralized glory posed a unique
challenge for a regime that really wants
to keep control over information States
of America is changing its relationship
with the people of Cuba the United
States will restore full diplomatic
relations with Cuba I believe that we
can do more to support the Cuban people
to the thawing of diplomatic relations
with Cuba to improve Cuba's internet
fleets us equipment to improve Cuba's
internet connect Cuba to the Internet
the surgeon internet usage one of the
companies watching closely Google Google
has gone to Cuba in a push for a free
and open Internet it hasn't been easy
for Google there's no internet not when
you land at the airport but we are right
now in one of these new Wi-Fi hotspots
that the government has set up just in
the last few weeks now to get on the
internet you have to buy a card like
this featuring a relaxed looking woman
in spandex meditating it costs two
dollars and with it you can go to one of
the 35 Wi-Fi hotspots in the country and
enter a code to get one hour of
unadulterated access to the uncensored
Internet the government often runs out
of these access cards so most people
have to buy them off a black market
dealer for three or four dollars since
these hotspots opened a couple months
ago people have been flocking to the
internet mainly to connect with family
members
are you going to think regarding the
never to be running a blog hop aroma
many Cubans buy into the official state
line that internet deficiency is caused
by a combination of the embargo from the
United States and a lack of telecoms
infrastructure a quick look into this
and you circa realize that the
infrastructure argument is completely
bogus in January 2013 a submarine
fiber-optic cable running from Venezuela
went live on the island the cable is
called Alba 1 and it was supposed to
support a more widespread and faster
internet on the island experts say that
with this cable connecting the island
should be easy when the network goes
online this summer Cuba's bandwidth will
increase by 3000 the question is will
Cubans then have access to the web
without restrictions and without excuses
Jake will cover the funeral did I mean
Silencio absolute Oh a contract patrol
Alissa row you Yahoo so basically each
time you complete a prohibition on
political hablar de las unity l internet
is incompatible immoral totally terrific
even Google's gone over the past year
year and a half they've made several
trips to Cuba they they offer it will
help you create that infrastructure and
and I believe that keeping government
politely declined that this is not an
infrastructure issue this leaked video
from a government training session shows
a presenter talking about the threat of
new technologies retama Faja l'ollonois
technology SacI mentaiko no selalu salah
empower their own interests
pero Sarika get us Ellen let me I wanna
rest upon another fight Cuba now employs
a cyber militia that has started
harassing and discrediting dissident
bloggers on the island but that doesn't
seem to stop them there are now 1,600
blogs run by Cubans
Johnny Sanchez is among the most visible
of these underground bloggers the idea
is that you know you on your 104
journalists so I'll write an article and
she'll get you know access to one of
these Wi-Fi points or the internet
somewhere and she'll email the article
to her colleagues in Spain or wherever
and they'll publish it and download all
that information onto a PDF
then send it back into the island you
know Remi said a visitor that's coming
with a flash drive Yoani considers this
the boomerang effect and then that gets
put on the flash drives and CDs and DVDs
and literally gets passed and
Lda Kagawa say on Pais donde la
información artisan tsurara I'll opinion
no sin peligro algo de la Renta Ramos o
monumento a la memoria flash for ghettos
of haters on Holly we're taught